the missile strike on Syria marks a
sudden shift by the Trump administration
the president said for years that the US
should not take military action against
Syria's government and Secretary of
State Rex Tillerson said just last week
that Syria's people will decide the
future of President Assad Margaret
Brennan is in Palm Beach Florida where
President Trump is meeting with China's
leader again today Margaret good morning
good morning well president Trump has
shown he is willing to use at least
limited military action to enforce that
redline against chemical weapons first
drawn by his predecessor the Trump
administration believes that Bashar
al-assad has used sarin gas in at least
three attacks over the past two weeks
Assad choked out the lives of helpless
men women and children in a late
evenings statement President Trump said
the images of small children choking to
death on poison gas moved him to action
it was a slow and brutal death for so
many even beautiful babies the decision
to strike was made after the president
arrived Thursday in Palm Beach for a
summit with Chinese President Xi Jinping
before their dinner mr. Trump consulted
with National Security Advisor HR
McMaster and defense secretary mattis
shortly after the meal the strikes
commenced
the president first publicly indicated
he was considering action following
Wednesday's meeting with Jordan's King
the president worried that toxic agents
could end up in the hands of terrorists
and use that threat as justification for
striking without the permission of
Congress it is in this vital national
security interest of the United States
to prevent and deter the spread and use
of deadly chemical weapons Secretary of
State Rex Tillerson said the sarin gas
attacks were a clear violation of the
2013 diplomatic deal that Russia and the
u.s. brokered to have Syria hand over
its chemical stockpile he said after
President Obama had turned a blind eye
to Assad's repeated violations in action
in Syria was not an option for president
Truong previous attempts at changing
Assad's behavior have all failed and
failed very dramatically
now these serious strikes may help
China's President Xi Jinping to gauge
mr. Trump's willingness to act against
nuclear-armed North Korea those two meet
leaders meet today and Gayle next week
secretary Tillerson flies to Moscow
where he is expected to discuss Syria
with Vladimir Putin should be quite a
meeting thank you very much Margaret